[Sebastian Thrun - Research Professor, Stanford University - Fellow and VP, Google] So this is a really exciting event for us.
We are launching now our new University Udacity. This is our very first class with David.
David, what is this class all about?
[David Evans - Professor, University of Virginia]
So welcome to the first class.
This is a class that's going to introduce you to computer science,
and we're going to do that by building a search engine.
You're not expected to have any previous background in computing to take this class.
It's fine if you've never programmed before. That's what we expect.
You're going to learn some of the core ideas in computer science.
You're going to learn to program in a language called Python,
and you're going to build a search engine that by the end of 7 weeks
will have all the main components of a search engine like Google in it.
Learning about computing is really one of the most powerful things you can do.
Computers are these amazing machines that can be programmed to do anything.
And once you learn a little bit about programming, you can sort of start to envision
the power that you have, the things that you can build with computers.
One of the great things about computing is that you don't really need a lot of resources
to build something that can change the world.
If you learn a little bit, if you have a creative idea,
you can build something, you can deploy your application to millions of people
on the Internet, and it doesn't really take a lot of resources to do that.
It just takes a little creativity and a little bit of knowledge.
So David, this is really exciting. I'm looking forward to seeing your class.
I'll be making occasional appearances, but I have my own class to teach.
But David will teach this wonderful class, and I think we should just dive in.
Great! Well, let's get started.